bonjour à temps je crois que je vais
refaire ma phrase par an depuis je
refais alors dans la première saison à
lisser le drh ils s'aiment bien et le
drh lui propose d'aller boire un verre
ils sont tous les deux très timide et
très émue et à la saison 2 ils soient
ensemble mais du coup ils le cachent aux
autres et à la fin il doit je spoile pas
tout il doit en gros le virer quelqu'un
de l'entreprise et c'est un peu ou lui
ou elle du coup elle est super énervés
et la saison 3 il travaille ensemble ce
sont des ex et c'est la guerre et en
plus elle devient sa supérieure
hiérarchique donc ça se passe pas très
bien ça va [ __ ] un peu la merde dans
la saison 3
les rencontres que j'ai eues l'adorent
sur les tournages c'est souvent ceux qui
s'occupent du hm chmc c'est le
maquillage la coiffure les costumes et
avec eux on fait un petit transfert
entre qui on est et quel personnage on
va jouer on arrive à billets en nous et
on va se transformer en un personnage et
ils savent tous nous le bureau du
bonheur ce serait de travailler au
printemps dehors avec des copains et mon
chat qui serait là qu'ils seraient
heureux aussi de ce qui pourrait se
balader n'inventerait du genre de
sketches d'épisodes et on se montrerait
déclic et on rigolerait beaucoup je
m'étais retrouvé chez pôle emploi et
j'avais une espèce de cession c'était un
enfer en était en rond j'étais obligé de
participer à ça et on devait dire qu'est
ce qu'il fallait mettre sur notre cv
c'était un tour de table on disait une
photo oui il faut mettre une photo dire
ce qu'on a fait comme expérience
oui et je me suis dit qu'il fallait
peut-être faire tout le contraire et
gonfler son cv peut-être que ça marche
mieux comme ça
je constate que quand un mec poussant un
espèce de coup de gueule souvent ça
passe j'entends souvent non mais lui il
est sanguin il est très caractériel
c'est comme si ça ça fait partie de sa
personnalité et quand une fille pousse
une gueulante la même chose mais
j'entends des gens me dire oui alors un
peu déraillé est toxique ou se méfier
d'elle
j'aimerais pouvoir me mettre en colère
au même titre qu'un mec et qu'on me dise
à elle et sanguine voilà mon à cholet
qu'écrit entre autres sorcières elle est
un peu avec moi
on peut tout le temps orelsan
je trouve qu'il écrit trop bien puis là
un espèce de second degré un côté provoc
que j'aime beaucoup
y'a pas longtemps j'ai vu antoine est
dans les cévennes je me suis dit ça doit
être génial de jouer dans quelque chose
comme ça d'aussi libre et drôle ça doit
être assez génial j'espère que j'aurai
commencé à faire de la danse parce que
j'ai voulu faire de la danse à 18 ans la
danse classique je me suis dit ah mais
non commencés par la danse classique à
18 ans et aujourd'hui j'ai 34 ans j'ai
toujours pas commencé la danse donc
j'espère que notre disant je pourrais
dire que que je fais de la danse
[Musique]